turning overseas now where China's
government faced some of the largest
public protests in decades as over the
weekend demonstrators in the capital of
Beijing and other cities called on the
country's President to resign over
strict covid-19 lockdown policies that
have nonetheless failed to stop the
virus from spreading Elizabeth Palmer
has more now on the angry protests that
have also spread online
a man shouts what until now few would
even have dared say aloud down with Xi
Jinping down with the Communist Party
there were public protests across the
country over the weekend in at least 10
cities including Shanghai we reached one
of the protesters there on Sunday night
how angry are people with the lockdown
because
they're very angry
we agreed to hide her identity as this
interview could get her arrested
over the weekend an unknown number of
protesters was arrested including the
BBC's cameraman though he was later
released the protests are by far the
biggest challenge yet to Xi Jinping zero
covid policy which has battered the
economy and locked down hundreds of
millions of people what do your friends
say about the Chinese government's
management
of covid people don't do not support it
at all the anger was actually sparked by
a tragedy thousands of miles away in
xinjiang western China 10 people burned
to death in an apartment fire last week
a furious crowd gathered round the
government offices convinced that
coveted restrictions had stopped the
fire engines from reaching The Blaze
authorities denied that but the story
was a Tipping Point people gathered at
vigils in sympathy with the victims and
some held up blank pieces of paper to
symbolize the way critical voices in
China are silenced by Sunday night this
largely peaceful but utterly
unprecedented descent had spread even to
the capital Beijing
now everyone is wondering how the
government will react but XI jinping's
commitment to mass testing lockdowns and
vast warehouses for isolating coveted
contacts is core policy and the site of
citizens chanting lift lockdowns isn't
likely to change his mind for CBS
mornings Elizabeth Palmer Tokyo